hey guys I'm Jess McDonald it is the 7th
of April and the show you're watching is
games but news today Microsoft in making
your wallets happy by continuing to
sweeten that titanfall bundle the bundle
which consisted of the shooter and an
Xbox one for 450 bucks will now be
packed in with a 12-month subscription
to xbox live which would normally set
you back another 60 bucks if you want to
pick it up head to target though it's
still $50 cheaper if you grab it from
their online store and you can swap out
titanfall for 4 to 5 if you're so
inclined those fans are talked about his
feelings today well mostly the
controversy over the Xbox one's policies
on DRM which apparently hurt him
personally the new head of Xbox said he
knows Microsoft built Xbox for the right
reasons and that the company should have
done more to communicate this at the
time Spencer said some of the decisions
made me didn't land all were the right
decisions and we changed some of those
but this is a company that has the
resources to really do things that
change the world let me know what you
think of Phil Spencer's comments in our
comments section we may be getting a
brand new Borderlands installment if a
report from games points now.com is to
be believed apparently the game won't be
the next full sequel but rather a pre
sequel to bridge the gap between the
events of Borderlands 1 and 2 according
to the report the game is coming to xbox
360 ps3 and pc sometime this fall and
will center around a younger handsome
jack you'll be able to play as one of
his four lieutenants Athena the
gladiator Wilhelm the enforcer anisha
the LOB ringer and frag trap who is
supposedly a militarized claptrap the
game is said to be set on the moon of
Elvis and Hyperion's iconic 8 shaped
base from Borderlands 2 and will offer a
bazillion weapons to choose from so
basically it's your standard Borderlands
entry blast off the mark today
backwards-compatibility could be coming
to the Xbox one but the when is pretty
damn vague Microsoft has said they're
looking at Xbox 360 emulation plans but
they're still working on how to
implement them at this stage
as reported by Kotaku development late
Frank Savage has said that one of the
challenges is shifting from the PowerPC
processor in the 360 to the x86 in the
Xbox one as a result he said there are
plans but we're not done thinking them
through yet unfortunately do you guys
think we need to see backwards
compatibility come to the new generation
consoles or not you can leave me all of
your thoughts in that comment section
down below or on my Twitter where I'm at
just McDonnell that is it from me today
but I'll be back with even more news
same time tomorrow so I do hope I'll see
them